so he starts saying I got a gift for you
I got a give and I grew up in like a
broken neighborhood you know I thought
it was gonna be his talk you know so I
start practicing my like see a like
don't be interested face
welcome to this is not happening
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. hey there you
go boys drink up nobody's gonna remember
what the hell's happenin tonight that
dudes trying to get my couch pregnant
being out the window man John Legend
bought me that piano
throw the ball pick
[Applause]
we can discover boy like me I'm a sober
guy appreciate it I didn't want to be
but this is what happened I was in New
York City right New York City New York
they call it the same thing right back
in front of each other just to really
piss you off before they get there it's
like we heard you in the beginning you
know but I was in New York City uh east
of Hoboken and I hadn't planned on doing
any cocaine okay I planned on doing this
much cocaine that's a zero amount you
know but apparently some cocaine a panel
getting together with me when it left
his home that evening so I went to this
party man and my friends were at this
party and and I felt uncomfortable when
I got to this party
probably because like when I really
think back on my life like I've always
just felt uncomfortable you know like I
don't know what it is like my whole life
has just been this constant struggle
with every moment like I'm just
wrestling with every second just to feel
okay like I don't even want to feel good
just sent me in the middle you know so
I'm at this party and I'm feeling how I
feel regularly uncomfortable so I
decided to have some drinks because my
friends are alcoholics and I'm
competitive so I have a couple tequila's
right and tequila let's be honest like
poor Mexico right into your body okay I
mean make you jump offense make you buy
a gun
make you run across a highway with your
family make you knock a woman up make
you knock a woman down okay
Oh Lady Janet you know so I had me a
couple tequila's and uh and I was
feeling alive you know I was feeling a
little more comfortable now 1:30 in the
morning I left this I left this party
because at 6:30 a.m. I had to be on the
nationally syndicated radio program the
Opie and Jim Norton radio show and it's
a yeah it's a wonderful show that tapes
there in New York City in New York and
and those are two men that I really
admire you know and admire is when
somebody's better than you but you still
like them it's an old-fashioned ideal so
at 1:30 a.m. I get into this taxicab
write this beautiful asian girl that I
do not know gets into the taxi with me
we're both headed the same way they call
it sharing a taxi okay and this girl
lays the back of her head right into my
lap and I'm thinking yeah you know
New York's got these beautiful free
asian girls with every taxi ride
this is a marvelous accoutrement to the
city you know uber no thank you taxi you
have won me back so this girl's just
laying in my lap and she just starts
ruminant about her evening you know she
said she said she had a nice evening but
that her boyfriend wasn't in town that
he's never in town then she goes what
happens in taxis stays in tactics and
I'm not the brightest you know bowling
the bold roar did you ever wander into a
sense you're like but I'm looking around
this vehicle after she says that and I'm
thinking this is a taxi you know being
taxi me once shame on me so I'm feeling
kind of cavalier after her statements
right
I go down to make a kiss you know this
young lady is laying in my lap I go down
to make a kiss now trying to kiss
somebody that's laying in your lap
that's a beautiful idea until you get
right here okay
and then you're just milling around like
a lip rapist bro I don't think James
Bond could kiss a woman laying in his
lap okay so she pushed me off of her she
called me a creep she call me up call me
a pervert
definitely not a creep and then it was
awkward for a few blocks until she got
dropped off wherever she was going I'm
not sure even where it was I think it
was like a halfway house for complete
or something and at that point
it's just me and the driver you know and
and I thought he said drugs he could
have said something else English wasn't
his first language you know he was by
language but I heard drugs in my head
you know and so I said cocaine like I
was coke stirrer for Columbus breath and
we just landed on crack rock you know
and I heard him accelerate that vehicle
and that's universal language for we're
gonna get some cocaine cuz that's a drug
to me you know we we deserve confusing
spice
I mean we don't make you forget how to
get home cocaine will make you forget
how to get to heaven so we just drove
man man we just drove man and uh we
drove for about a half hour into like
North Harlem if that's even a place I
don't even know but it was a dark
neighborhood that's not a euphemism all
the streetlights were busted out so you
couldn't tell that it was predominantly
black but I grew up in a black
neighborhood I know when I'm back you
know and we got there man and I gave
this dude some money he gets out of the
vehicle comes back a few minutes later
with some cocaine on him you know but he
sits in the back seat next to me a
little alarming you know I feel like
when you're in the air on a plane and
you see the pilot taking a piss you're
like what the is this spirit but
this beautiful gentleman scooped up a
little bit of cocaine on the car key put
it under my nose kill that baby brother
and I scooped him once and he killed his
man and then and and just a couple of
dueling cocaine Asst and we got high man
we got high for about 40 minutes dude I
read I remember being so high at one
point I was like dude where the is
a driver bruh
and he didn't know so we sat there man
we continue to get high together me and
as beautiful gentleman and he said Luigi
that was his name
Luigi and I thought that was Spanish you
know like that rare Italian Spanish so I
start saying my name is Spanish Teodoro
because I learned Spanish in Louisiana
and my whole life I thought Teodoro was
Spanish for Theodore which is my first
name about six months ago this girl goes
that means I adore you wish you would
have told me at some other point you
know because it's fine right it's fine
to tell people you adore them when you
meet them but when you're an hour deep
into an Eightball with a man who keeps
saying he's Luigi and you just keep
saying I adore you too well 99% of the
time this don't in heterosexually so
this is a long night man
so he starts saying I got a gift for you
I got a give and I grew up in like a
broken neighborhood you know I thought
it was gonna be his talk you know so I
start practicing my like see a like
don't be interested face
from running through the rolodex of no
for me faces and huh and then he
keeps saying I got a gift for gifts I
got a gift for you then I'm thinking
it's like a thing on his phone you know
like a gif you know like a like a
disappointed walrus you know but then I
hear on the taxi door and I'm like who
knocks on a car door dude come in or
just be out there we who raised in a
house of car doors in it so I'm like
come in cuz now I gotta live in this
universe they created by knocking
and a toot gets in a prostitute you know
- you can't say Pross process somebody
that uh have a prosthetic you know and a
to get mad if you call them across if uh
if they got everything you know
so I'm being politically correct and I'm
saying this - you know and I respect
prostitutes I respect all women you know
whether they're a president or a
prostitute I respect a man you know
prostitute probably a tougher job let's
be honest these days dude you out there
middle of the night slang in that canal
you know a lot of men are gay market
shares decline so I respect prostitutes
man but I don't want to deal with the
prostitute tonight I just want to do
cocaine with my adorable buddy Louie you
know in this prostitute man she had like
uh you know she had a wig that covered
you could see about 60% of her face okay
and to me it look like a man's face
right which is fine you know no judgment
there I'm just saying if I were on a
game show called guess 60% of this first
this is famous
I would guess man first to know but so
we're all we're all back there getting
high together and this prostitute starts
making advances towards me and I don't
want a prostitute so I start feeling
uncomfortable which is where I live at
most of the time so it only took me
about half a long to get there you know
so I get out of the taxi into the street
in North Harlem right luigi comes out
after me because that's new friendship
and he's like hundred dollars hundred
dollars hundred dollars so I give him a
hundred bucks I'm thinking he's gonna
pay this - sure go on about her business
we'll get back to you know you know
friendship I'll look over a minute later
they're kissing on each other's necks
okay he's investing my hundred back here
with this prostitute I still have a $240
meter on the front of this taxi right so
I'm out 360 not even in the vehicle
unfair but I deal with my negative
feelings outside of the car so I don't
bring negative energy back into the
vehicle right
then I get back into the taxi but now
I'm sitting in the front passenger seat
right you can hear Luigi and the tune in
the back you can hear the light
rustlings of a blowjob you know kind of
just just simmering up into existence a
good blowjob - it sounds like you know
one you see on the Internet it sound
like somebody's at a water park
and I respect what they're doing man but
I still want to do cocaine by myself
right so now I'm trying to be
considerate and quietly do cocaine by
myself right just a sawfish little coke
head you ever met dude just like a just
like a newborn rabbit just happened upon
a gram you know at one point I was
leaning my head back and just quietly
dumping cocaine into the bottom of my
nose it was awesome bro Luigi's in the
bag dude he's at the water park bro he
got that all-day wristband dude he don't
give a about me
he goes you drive you drive and this is
when I knew I had a problem man
not specifically with drugs and alcohol
but with the way that I behave when I'm
on drugs and alcohol when I moved over
into the driver seat of this taxi right
put on my seatbelt I remember asking
them to put their seatbelt on but they
don't even make a seatbelt for all that
activity you know when he seatbelt
reform I've been saying this and I
started this vehicle and I drove us off
in the North Harlem man at 4:15 in the
morning just driving drove probably
about 20 minutes didn't know I was you
know my brain's like damn do you're lost
it's 4:30 in the morning man you're high
on cocaine but at least you're working
least you're out here making money for
your family okay I don't have a family
do
more importantly I don't drive taxi bro
but then my brain also goes but man you
don't have a commercial driver's license
as if that was going to be a issue when
the cop stops us there's empty cocaine
bags everywhere right look look like
I've been washing my face with powdered
donut the sex crimes in the backseat
potentially gay sex crimes in the
backseat and that officers just gonna be
like that's all for not young soldier
you don't ever show first certificate
but that's what got me to pull over man
I pulled over I left a couple hundred
dollars on that car seat I started
walking off man I walked about three
blocks got into a regular taxi right I
I even made him pop the trunk just to
make sure that spare tire wasn't
shooting up in the back you know I get
to my hotel it's 5:30 in the morning and
in one hour I gotta be on the nationally
syndicated radio program the Opie and
Jim Norton radio show two men that I
really admire so I finished doing my
cocaine because you can't not finish
your cocaine to try to not finish your
cocaine
I'm watch you drop what do they put in
it cigarettes
I took three showers in ten minutes son
and dried off after each one bro you
don't know me then I start walking to
the radio station right it's five blocks
to the serious building halfway there I
realize that I have on jeans with
sweatpants over them something I've
never worn before because nobody's ever
worn it
I'm the Neil Armstrong of pants this
morning I get up to the radio station
they tell me I gotta be in the air for
three hours
there's a million listeners right I
can't feel my face with either hand
hi ii feel my neck running on neck
thoughts and the other guest for the day
is Darryl Strawberry yeah
who's in the Hall of Fame he's a Hall of
Fame baseball player and he's in the
Hall of Fame for cocaine what an eight
ball this beautiful man couldn't hit
right and bless his heart man he's 13
years sober and he's eloquent and
successful and well put together and he
was some of these ideas that I maybe I
envisioned myself as but this morning
I'm showing up you know nothing like
that you know so it just made me think
like dude you got to tighten up you know
and I'll say this too about Darryl
Strawberry man I have big nostrils
Darryl Strawberry gots the biggest
nostrils you ever seen I'm not saying it
to shame him it's not an ethnic thing
this man got dead stars at the bottom of
his nose okay
and I just say it so that you understand
he didn't stand a chance against a fine
powder this beautiful man could kill a
spice rack from 70 feet away okay take
that nutmeg what you looking at
coriander but on this day he was
everything I needed to see you know so
yeah so that's when I got sober now been
sober for 11 months and I'm Theo von
thank you for having me you guys be good
[Applause]